vamos a multiplicar 4 por 80 podemos
decir tenemos 4 veces el número 80 así
que tenemos el número 80 una vez dos
veces tres veces y cuatro veces aquí
tenemos el número 80 cuatro veces
podemos calcular esto sumando todos
estos 80s y llegar a la solución pero
vamos a resolverlo de otra manera vamos
a seguir con la multiplicación una forma
de hacerlo es descomponer este 80 y
conocemos el patrón de multiplicar por
10 vamos a descomponer este 80 para
obtener un 10 tenemos 4 por y en lugar
de 80 pongamos 8 por 10 ya que 88 por 10
son iguales son equivalentes podemos
reemplazar nuestro 80 con el 8 por 10 y
ya tenemos este por 10 aquí que nos va a
ser muy útil ya que tenemos un patrón
que nos va a ser muy útil con esta parte
de multiplicar por 10 primero
multiplicamos esto 4 por 8 que es 32 y
ahora tenemos 32 por 10 y ahora usamos
nuestro
de multiplicar por 10 que es que cuando
multiplicamos un número entero por 10
tomamos ese número entero en este caso
el 32 y le agregamos un 0 al final así
que 32 por 10 es 320 y hay una razón por
la que este patrón funciona y la vimos
en otro vídeo aquí lo revisamos
rápidamente 32 por 10 es igual a 32
decenas y podemos hacer varios ejemplos
digamos que tenemos 3 por 10 serán 3
decenas o 10 más 10 más 10 que es igual
a 30 nuestro número entero con un 0 al
final si tenemos 12 por 10 serán 12
decenas y si los contamos todos
tendremos 120 que nuevamente es nuestro
número entero con un 0 al final así que
podemos usar este patrón aquí para decir
que 32 por 10 es 32 con 10 al final
hagamos otro ejemplo ahora digamos que
vamos a tener 300 vamos a tener centenas
en lugar de decenas 300 por 6
300 lo podemos descomponer como lo
hicimos con el 80 en el ejemplo anterior
podemos decir que 300 es 100 veces 3 o 3
veces 100 y seguimos teniendo nuestra
multiplicación por 6 y esta expresión
300 por 6 es igual a esta expresión de
100 por 3 por 6 ya que reemplazamos
nuestro 300 por este 100 por 3 aquí
vamos a multiplicar y primero
multiplicamos nuestros números de un
dígito 3 por 6 3 por 6 es igual a 18 y
este 18 lo multiplicamos por 100 o lo
que es lo mismo 18 centenas como 18 y
para señalar las centenas ponemos dos
ceros al final 18 centenas o 1.800 y
como vimos aquí 300 es igual a 3 por 100
este tres con dos ceros al final lo
mismo pasa aquí abajo tenemos este 18%
es este 18 con dos ceros al final así
que 300 por 6 es igual a 1800 o
dieciocho centenas hagamos otro problema
pero ahora agreguemos otra posición de
valor y tengamos miles tenemos siete por
siete mil como en los ejercicios
anteriores vamos a descomponer nuestros
siete mil y siete mil es lo mismo que
siete veces mil mil siete veces y
seguimos teniendo nuestra multiplicación
por siete aquí de nuevo multiplicamos
primero nuestros números de un solo
dígito 7 por 7 que es igual a 49 y 49
por 1000 va a ser igual a 49 mil así que
aquí escribimos nuestro 49 y quizá ya el
patrón se volvió bastante claro pues
vamos a ponerle tres ceros al final 49
con tres ceros que es lo mismo que 49
mil igual que aquí arriba
7 por mil es igual a 7 mil 17 con 30 49
por 1000 es igual al 49 con tres ceros
al final o 49 mil y ya que comprendimos
bien el patrón vamos a usarlo de nuevo
tenemos 9 por 50 hagamos otro que sea
igual a 9 por 500 y hagamos otro más que
será 9 por 5000 los invito a que pausa
en el vídeo y traten de resolver cada
uno de estos ejercicios por su cuenta
traten de encontrar la solución para
cada una de estas expresiones con lo que
acabamos de ver vamos a resolverlos
juntos 9 por 50 va a ser igual a 9 por 5
por 10 ya que descompusimos nuestros 50
en 5 por 10 hacemos las multiplicaciones
9 por 5 es igual a 45 le agregamos un 0
al final 9 por 500 es igual a 9 por 5
por 100 500 es igual a 5 centenas de la
misma forma que 50
eran cinco decenas hacemos la
multiplicación 9 por 5 sigue siendo 45
pero ahora agregaremos 20 al final 45
centenas y finalmente 9 por 5000 va a
ser igual a 9 por 5 por mil porque 5000
es igual a 5 por mil o 5 veces 1000
multiplicamos 9 por 5 sigue siendo 45 y
en esta ocasión agregamos 3 ceros
tenemos 45 mil cuando multiplicamos cada
una de estas expresiones podemos ver que
lo único diferente es el número de ceros
al final así que el patrón es que cada
vez que multiplicamos un número entero
por 10 agregamos un 0 al final de
nuestro número cada vez que
multiplicamos un número entero por 100
le vamos a agregar dos ceros al final y
al multiplicar por mil agregaremos tres
ceros y ya que conocemos este patrón lo
podemos usar para ayudarnos con
expresiones como estas en donde
inicialmente no vemos
es un 100.000 pero podemos obtenerlos
al descomponer estos números y así
obtener un 10 un 100.000 para ayudarnos
a resolver el problema